[Musique]
il ya une instance au québec qui peut
agir lors de situations d'urgence
majeure pour coordonner tous les
intervenants ce qui aurait dû être le
cas selon plusieurs dans la gestion de
la crise sur l'autoroute 13 c'est
l'organisation de la sécurité civile du
québec
le sinistre qui faisait le débat avait
pris une ampleur insoupçonnée
ça existe depuis les années 50 en raison
de la guerre froide
mais après un cafouillage dans la
gestion des incendies des bpc en 1988 à
saint basile le grand
le gouvernement avait dû rajuster le tir
voici michel c'est doré un ancien
responsable à la sécurité civile que
s'est il passé à l'époque
et qu'est ce qu'on a appris le temps on
a évacué les gens mais après ça l'autre
défi c'était déterminer à quel moment on
peut permettre aux gens de revenir ça a
été l'élément qui a fait perdurer le
sinistre et faire évoluer vers une crise
une leçon succès c'est qu'on ne
regroupait les ressources du
gouvernement du québec dans des missions
alors quand on est rendus au stade
d'avoir une réponse gouvernemental en
sécurité civile parce que nécessaire
mais il ya des conséquences qui
dépassent la capacité de réponse
usuelles de là l'importance d'avoir une
architecture prévu à l'avance pour
mobiliser les capacités puis partager
l'information l expertise fut la
sécurité civile est intervenue souvent
deux à trois fois par année
par exemple lors de l'incendié d'une
montagne de pneus en 1990 à saint-amable
au déluge du saguenay en 1996 à la
tempête du verglas en 1998 où des
milliers de québécois ont manqué
d'électricité aux inondations en
gaspésie en 2007 à la crise de la grippe
h1n1 en 2009 à lac-mégantic en 2013
est ce que chaque fois ça s'est passé
comme prévu et c'est quoi le protocole
en place par définition une catastrophe
ne survient pas comme ça c'est comme
c'était prévu devenait que le corps ou
une statue est débordé ou plusieurs
municipalités sont sollicités en même
temps une structure régionale du
gouvernement du québec qui se met en
oeuvre et dans ce même principe de
subsidiarité
on va se retrouver avec une région qui
si elle est débordée on va mettre en
place l'organisation de sécurité civile
du québec
il peut y arriver dans certains corps
assez rare encaisse sa viande l'inversé
l'ol
c'est lui qui va déployer qui vont qui
va demander aux organisations régionales
de se mettre en place
quand ils les événements qu'on voit
venir une tempête de neige est un
exemple cette semaine une fonctionnaire
a perdu ses responsabilités au ministère
des transports pour ne pas avoir
déclenché une intervention de la
sécurité civile
en réaction à toutes ces personnes
prises au piège dans leur voiture sur
l'autoroute 13
tous les années les indications étaient
au rouge feu déclenché un processus sur
la sécurité civile une enquête demandée
par le gouvernement de philippe
couillard permettra de comprendre de
mieux comprendre en tout cas la série
d'erreurs qui a mené à ce cafouillage
qui a passera certainement à l'histoire
[Musique]